genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by nordvpn if you're
going online and you're doing it
unprotected out there my friends what
are you doing everybody is snoop snoop
snooping on your stuff and that's where
a VPN comes in you need to browse safely
right I've been using n VPN for quite a
while and I freaking freaking like it I
always talk about browsing internet and
doing it safely in a protected way and
you got to do it with
nordvp and my friend cyber security now
and cyber threats are a huge huge thing
that everybody's talking about and
that's why once again if you're online
and you're not using a VPN specifically
nordvpn you don't know what you're doing
it's super easy so why don't you just
get it my friends listen here's the
exclusive deal grab the nordvpn deal go
to nordvpn.com genius brand and get
extra subscription time try it risk-free
now with a 30-day money back guarantee
and thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring our
show genius boy listeners this podcast
is brought to you by by fume cold turkey
may be great on sandwiches but there's a
better way to break your bad habits
we're not talking about some weird mind
voodo from your crazy neighbor we're
talking about fume my friends we are
sponsored by fume and they look at the
problem in a different way not
everything in a bad in bad habit is
wrong so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit my friend my
fume is freaking cool ooh The Taste the
first time I tried it amazing feels
super refreshing the feel dude it's
super well weighted perfectly balanced
and extremely fun to fidget with um how
beautiful is the real wood on it the
shapes you feel really cool using it man
I have it it has like this natural wood
look to it and I got to tell you guys
man the taste pretty freaking amazing I
freaking love it stopping is something
we all put off because it's hard but
switching the fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun join fum and accelerating
Humanity's uh breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to Tri
fum.fi pack today that's TR f.com and
use code genius to save an additional
10% off your order today today the way
that you can use emotional truth in
entertainment art or whatever right
Eminem killing his wife yeah did he no
no no but it was a hit song Stan you
know did that guy really no maybe the
emotional truth behind that is like he
had a very rocky relationship with his
ex-wife the other one being his fans are
crazy as [__] yeah right but did these
stories really happen no he he he
painted a picture he told a story kind
of in 5 4 3 2 1 what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast I am your host David so
and then we have the two EDS together
dude what's up the Fraternal EDS you
guys always mix them up every time I I
sometimes I tag them wrong
too today is a very interesting day my
friends oh have you guys heard of the um
have you guys heard of knees over toes
knees over toes there was this guy he
started this program called uh like atg
uh I I forgot what it's called exactly
but he uh played basketball Sports his
whole life and you know I have like
[__] up knees and so his stuff has I
don't know this phone listens to
everything that I do so if I talk about
my [__] up knees guess what pop pops
on Instagram knees over toes guy and I
actually heard about him through I I've
seen his stuff constantly I actually
bought his book a while ago and I was
applying some of his stuff a while back
but I I didn't really start doing it
until recently because uh have you guys
ever went Grunion here no I mean I know
I know of it khif actually put me on it
yeah so we went Grant hunting and I was
having so much [__] fun I was like
juking these fishes and like pushing
kids over to grab this fish well I
[__] popped my knee like about a
couple of months ago and I haven't I
didn't feel any pain I didn't know and
then the next morning my [__] knee
swelled up oh oh gosh I couldn't walk
rewind what is runion Hun
no so grunions are these like little
silver fish that during M mating season
they just wash up up you just grab them
and you them hell sorry philophobia I'm
not if if you hit if you hit like a good
spot it's like hundreds of them just
like SW all over free gross Zing
gross yeah so we went gruning hunting I
got a bunch I cooked it all everything
else and the next day my knee swelled up
I haven't felt that type of pain since I
had it popped like a Jiu-Jitsu so I was
like what the [__] happened and it sucks
because once you damage it everything
that you've done to rehab it goes
backwards again so I was back at square
one where I would try to do a lunge and
my knee would rock like this I couldn't
even do a lunge so I started doing the
atg stuff the the knees over toe stuff
this is not a paid sponsorship by the
way but I started doing some of his
stuff is programming and my [__] knee
feels so much better like it's [__]
nuts I've done so many different types
of rehab [__] and this [__] random
Instagram ad from this guy is like
saving my [__] knee cuz I don't want
surgery so there's just some series of
exercises yeah so like I guess you know
have you guys when you start learning
how to do squats like the the common
thing that everybody would mention was
that your knees aren't supposed to go
past your toes right they say that it's
bad form it's pressures on your kneecap
for him through his own research and his
own injuries and everything else he
started going backwards and saying like
actually if you look at like um like
Asian people or whatever you know we do
like the smoking Squad that was like one
of his references it's like how come
these old Asian people have great
[__] needs It's like because they
smoke
cigarettes it's true it's true though
it's true you get started early man 11
years 12 years old yeah so you know he
was doing his research of like okay well
what the [__] is with these Asian people
like they're you know they their knes
are fine till they're old age like
they're going up picking up their
grandchildren they're going way past
over their toes there was like um a
research he did about I think it was
Asian or Russian about farmers who uh
they plow their fields but they do this
thing where they move backwards and it
also helps with their knee Health as
well so all this other stuff I've been
applying and I've been able to kind of
get into a deeper squat which I haven't
been able to do in two or three years so
I've been doing that [__] [__] and
I'm going tell you right now join the
NBA soon guys
nice no complete opposite you sound like
an old [__] talking about you're
going to see at the stretches and and
KNE I just want to be able to smoke a
cigarette and squat down again you're
going to see you at the next Isa
basketball tournament yeah no simu won't
let me there dude yeah they're going to
choose either simu or me and they're
going to who's coming no I know he's
just going to do a back flip out of
nowhere like he always does yeah shout
outs to to my best friend
uh any speaking about people that nobody
likes
um I'm kidding I just I can't help it
he's perfectly fine seg got a segue like
that he did great in Barbie dude he
played
himself
uh so Hassan minhaj right has been under
a lot of fire recently and I and I sent
um the both EDS to to go ahead and read
up about this because there's a lot to
unpack on this stuff right yeah and
listen just to give a a background like
I haven't really watched too much of
hass's stuff right and if I were to be
straightforward about it I I he's not
very funny to me um and I've tried
watching his things you know yeah yeah
like I wouldn't put him in like a pure
class of Comedy like a pure comedian
yeah you know yeah so like when I so I
was telling this to Ed outside so years
ago when he brought out his special I I
didn't know who he was and you know he
was becoming like a hotter comic or what
ever whatnot that was the conversation I
wasn't a part of so people were like oh
have you seen this Hassan minhaj stuff
or whatever and I saw this thing pop up
on Netflix and I watched it I was like
and I watched it halfway through I was
like I don't want to listen to a TED
Talk and so I'm like okay cool whatever
and then I was talking to somebody else
like oh did you watch hson standup I was
like no I saw his Ted Talk I I didn't
know he had a standup on Netflix as well
and then he sent me a link and I was
like wait that's the special you saw I
was like I did see it I thought it was a
TED Talk and so this kind of goes into
this conversation not about the topic
that we're going to talk about but a lot
of comics do talk about this and I think
a lot of people who consume comedy talk
about this too it's like what is this
[__] like is this standup or is it not
like there's no punchlines there's no
jokes and it's just somebody lecturing
you about their life and what you should
do emotionally right I think it's cuz he
came from The Daily Show exactly he was
a Daily Show correspondence that's how I
became aware of him um yeah cuz he was
one of the correspondents uh there on
the show already started politicized you
came from a political so it's when when
Trevor Noah was still hosting it speak a
little closer to oh it's when Trevor
Noah was still hosting it so oh okay see
now this starts to make a little more
sense right cuz when I was watching and
he had a couple of other specials or
another special that came out too which
is what a lot of people are referencing
but you know when I was watching his
stuff I was like where's the jokes is
there supposed to be a punchline
somewhere am I supposed to laugh
somewhere in this or is this like his
motivational speech it's it's kind of
like an extension of you know it's
political comedy I guess but um he had
I've seen I saw that for special and
then Netflix gave him a whole ass TV
show of their own kind of Daily Show
political news comedy show right cuz
everybody's doing that it's just like
late night talk show turned into
political comedy talk show because look
at uh step coar um that those late night
shows were not political like they were
just irrelevant they were Goofy they
were stupid um old man before him with
the glasses and David Letterman David
Letterman yeah he was not political
right and then coar comes in and he
comes from that background also on The
Daily Show also on the daily when John
Stewart was hosting yeah yeah he was
part of The Daily Show then he got his
own show which was the coar report and
then from there they they hired him to
replace David Letterman and they were
like well now he can't be political
right because they're thinking de
Letterman wise but coar is just that's
the way he is and so he actually started
beating um Jimmy Fallon in the ratings
because he was talking about politics
and stuff I mean Trump was really hot at
the time too right so I guess that's the
flavor from the past decade like
political comedy is getting a lot of
views and so the show on Netflix is like
an extension of that uh special where
it's just a big PowerPoint
presentation and what they he talks
about the news he talks about the issues
he has amazing Graphics by the way the
animation on those are excellent you it
it's just very political he gets the
facts and then he throws in some jokes
here and there but he is I guess I guess
you want to say one of those woke
comedians in a sense where his mission
behind it is for you know better human
rights you know equality equity and just
very liberal-minded just not making
people laugh yeah it's it's it's
basically political and social
commentary uh with a little bit of
joking in there right a tied to a lot of
his personal experiences so this is this
is where the the conversation really
starts about his stuff right so Hassan
has this whole thing
of it was it was a journalist that
decided to dig a little deeper into the
material that he was creating right and
it it was like originally a piece on on
him and then he was retelling those same
stories and they're journalists right so
they had a research research you know to
confirm these stor got fact checked
pretty much and then the article turned
into what it became yeah yeah and I
think that's such
a it's very weird right so the basically
for you guys who don't know what's going
on the the the biggest conversation
that's stemming from this is how much is
a comedian allowed to lie right and with
Hassan and we're going to go through the
very specific examples right but just to
give a general scope of this he's
telling these stories of like
specifically racial and political
atrocities that have happened to him
personally that turned out never [__]
happened yeah right never happened at
all the truth is maybe I would say if
I'm ballparking 10% yeah and the rest is
blatant lying we're not talking about
bending the truth we're talking about
outright he said he said it's it's the
it was his emotional truth which is just
the for [__] going to get to that
right so let's talk about the the first
thing that he did right or one of the
first examples that from what I remember
it was the whole U the anthrax scare
right so if you his daughter so anthrax
was this whole thing you know back in
the day if I'm pretty sure the young
people don't even remember this [__] but
it's basically uh it's poison right it's
a powdered poison goes into your system
[__] kills you or some [__] makes you
bleed from your eyes or some [__]
like that um so his whole thing was that
because of his political humor and the
stuff that he says that he is now being
personally attacked because he is this
Beacon of Hope of Truth or whatever and
so now his family is being attacked and
because he got this envelope that had a
powder something which was Anthrax it
got to his daughter they had a rush to
the hospital and his wife says this
emotional thing of like I don't care
what the [__] you do but if this affects
my family I will [__] leave you in a
heartbeat yeah okay so where's the uh
punch line to this where's the where's
the joke and and that was also uh I
guess following him talking about Jamal
kogi and that whole incident explain who
Jamal kogi is uh well he was a dude who
got disappeared basically he was a
journalist for the Washington Post yeah
um a resident of the United States not a
citizen yet but he was working on that
and so he had to go to the Embassy an
embassy I don't know why he ended up in
the Turkish Embassy yeah and then um the
prince of Saudi Arabia NBS I I don't
exactly know his full name Muhammad bin
Salam I forget who called Muhammad yeah
um sent some assassins to cut him to
pieces while he was alive apparently
there's an audio
recording I don't know how they have an
audio recording of it but for for the
Instagram the for the grab selfie yeah
they come to Pieces but Trump didn't
nothing about it um it just happened to
him and yeah yeah so yeah I don't know
where Hassan Minaj thinks he you know
applies himself to that but
basically I don't know all of these lies
have a tie towards him being victimized
well yeah it him being victim victimized
and also him appearing as a hero in some
instances right yeah and this is where
this this this starts to have this
conversation right where I I think what
I really disliked about his approach and
the way that he was answering the
journalist's question like questioning
his like validity right everything we're
going to get into this where he says
well no this didn't happen but it's my
stories are 70% emotional truth this is
one of the most laughable [__]
statements I've ever heard in my life it
reminds me of alternative facts right
alternative facts right it's like what
the [__] are you talking about aren't
you supposed to be an intelligent human
being and when we say stuff like
emotional truth right maybe that's a
conversation that you have with your
[__] wife you know what I'm saying
like therapist with a therapist not what
not with the and this is this is why
people are like well comedians lie I was
like
listen Comics do embellish the truth to
make a a story that actually happened
funn that's the key or if it's not true
it's ridiculous I'll give you a great
example right Dave Shel one of his
funniest bits was talking about him in a
sub when he was in a Subway where that
homeless person was jacking off holding
his dick and holding people hostage it's
so [__] ridiculous we know it's dumb
it's just a stupid stupid scenario yeah
did did David Chapelle actually do a
matrix move on the bus to avoid sperm
exactly no but it's funny or was was
there a baby on a street quarter selling
drugs exactly maybe yeah no but it's
[__] hilarious like we know it's not
true it's just a stupid [__] scenario
talking about how ghetto this area is
right it's these weird like possible
hypotheticals you the the emotional
truth in that joke is that he's a black
man afraid to be in the hood yeah that's
the joke that he himself is afraid of
that and we know that this is a fake
story off jump we already know yeah so
with hass's thing it's like he's tell
the story because it's true fact and by
the way he's using real people that
[__] exist well that's that's like a
whole other conversation and of itself
cuz I mean but I think it's all stemming
from what type of character this dude is
right and narcissist right a narcissist
um delusional right good looking guy T
and so a grifter definitely a grifter
right he is his lies are so [__]
ridiculous in the comedy realm like I
I'll give you another example of mine
right so I told a story on this podcast
of when I went to South Pasad there was
like this gym and I got you know this
[__] random dude attacked me at the
gym right how many how much of that was
embellishing how much was that true was
there a guy there 100% was there a Dude
that [__] attacked me 100% the stuff
that's embellished is me saying like oh
when he grabbed me it sounded like a DJ
scratching me I'm wind Breer but the
actual thing happened a real person
attacked me and I got a black eye right
these things actually [__] happen now
imagine if I told that story right and I
said and none of that [__] was true but
I said hey but you know what in reality
somebody out there did a got attacked
Asian hate so the point is is that our
people are getting attacked that's right
they are I didn't so I'm actually using
this thing to make myself look better
and for people to pity me I'm putting
myself here so I can tell this story so
I look amazing yeah that's [__]
[__] people would jump down my
throat they're like wait that wasn't
true so are you just using other
people's tragedy to make yourself look
really good that's essentially what this
[__] face is doing yeah so the other
example was also the homecoming story
right right so in that first special he
talks about a story where he he um has a
prom date set up with this white girl um
I don't know if we've mentioned yet
Hassan Manaj is an Indian American
Muslim right yes yeah and so he shows up
to the house um tuxedo flowers and when
he goes in she's already putting a
corset on some other dude right and her
parents were like it's just not a good
fit right you know doesn't want to be
seen with the brown boy yeah yeah and
then the punchline later on is that she
ended up marrying an Indian man you know
in the future and he somehow implements
that his rejection I don't know
enlightened her I some [__] it was
[__] yeah but it was all lies yeah
the problem with that is their family
receed threats for years because of that
right and and when all this comes to
light Hassan has no apologies he's not
apologetic at all matter of fact he
doubles down double down on saying it's
his emotional truth then you know it's
like how shitty of a human being can you
be to this person who she said oh we're
actually friends we're on really good
terms but you don't give a [__] that you
fabricated this whole [__] story you
got this [__] girl doxs and you're
like it's emotional truth no you lied
exactly you [__] piece of [__] you
[__] lied and then you almost [__]
somebody else's life over well he did he
did [__] them over cuz they were getting
threats they were legitimately getting
threats for years yeah I don't know if I
heard this right did he invite her to
that show and he told that story so
she's sitting there he's telling this
embellished lie um not even embellished
story just a lie straight up so
apparently what she says was that I Reed
way before yeah he asked her three days
before homecoming she already had a date
and so she said no I already have a date
and that was that mhm but that whole
thing where he showed up to her door
like and then it was like yeah and the
objective of that story to once again
isn't a joke the end there is no
punchline the the the that he's saying
is like [__] you Whitey this is what you
get I'm successful look at me you [__]
up because you didn't go to prom with me
and now I changed this person life I'm
I'm I'm the Messiah look what I did for
her EXA dude that's that that's the
whole thing about [__] nuts he's he's
he's like delusional it's like look you
can't emphasize a narrative about
victimization and heroism and when you
get called out on the [__] act like
but it's no biggie because uh it's again
based on my emotional truth your
emotional truth in that moment was
rejection yeah right yeah yeah exactly
and so if if the rejection wasn't enough
it's like he had to make a bigger crazy
make about race yeah make it about race
as to why he was rejected he [__]
some agenda it's it's it's coping at its
finest you know what I mean like this is
like another version of like Carlos
Mania he's like I think it's it's more
egregious than Carlos menia to be honest
with you cuz people are actually getting
hurt as a result of this whether it's
emot well hopefully not physically but
you know they they they have been
attacked right and the fact that well I
mean I think even aside from the whole
prom date thing what kind of sums it up
is the anthrax lie the the fact that
he's willing to use his family as pawns
to up himself I think that sums it up of
who this guy is so his emotional truth
was my wife threatened to divorce me
what's what's the story behind that
why which never happened it never even
happened no he's like you he's okay
using his own daughter as like [__]
comedic what I'm I'm saying that's what
I'm saying and not even comedic F where
is the joke no yeah there it's not the
it's not comedy it's it's again to
elevate his himself I'll give you yeah
and I'll give you a greater example
right so if his idea is that well this
stuff does happen in real life then why
didn't you just tell their stories right
and then you being such a great comic
why don't you go ahead and make it
[__] funny you jackass you [__]
piece of [__] you trash bag is your life
so [__] ter like so good that you
have no stories to tell I'm pretty sure
you do have stories to tell but instead
the end that's the problem that I have
with them too I think this is the
biggest issue is like I bet you he is a
good writer right he worked for the
Daily Show so you're a great writer you
know how to make things quote unquote
funny or you know how to create material
engaging exactly yeah get your audience
sucked into what you're saying they're
they're left silent they're not laughing
anymore it's serious
but it's like it's [__] [__] you
know so the thing is it's like so you
have these skills but the end goal is
evident the the your true stories
doesn't lead to you looking like an
amazing person right so your goal wasn't
to make people laugh it was to just put
yourself up here to say look I'm doing
this for you guys I'm I'm your political
Messiah I'm doing this for everybody
everybody look at me let me represent
heat I'm taking the heat for the sake of
repres a mar he's a hero he victim all
all inone for the sake of um comedy
somebody beat this Fool's ass please
agressive comedy well he he also says
too that you know when people come to
his show that they're expecting a
emotional roller coaster you know and so
it it again justifying why he's doing
what he's doing and why he's telling the
stories that he's telling and it's like
no bro so like for for me I don't think
this is a conversation necessarily of
uh how much can comedians lie you know
what I mean I I think it's a matter of
like what you lie about yeah you know
like look at when lately Dave Chappelle
has has these serious moments towards
the end of his of his uh comedy specials
right and those serious moments when it
gets quiet like is dealing with real
[__] and it and not about some scary
thing that happened to him and his
family right like that real [__] of when
he was victimized like that joke was
when when he got hit with a snowball
yeah and those kids called him the
n-word and what was the punchline he
made his mom suck his dick
yeah d drop the charges that's the joke
but the emotional truth is the [__] that
happened to him right yeah so it's like
maybe he's just bad at you know um
separating that line for what people you
know or I don't know if there rules bro
that's like compulsive lying though you
know what I mean I don't I don't even
think it's a matter of he's having a
hard time distinguishing that line and
and you know like we're using Dave
Chappelle too as a great example because
Dave does intertwine a lot of serious
topics with his with his stand up but at
the end of the day we're left laughing
our [__] ass off and for him and Dave
is not praising himself there is no
self-gratification of him putting
himself up like if he told that story
about his transf friend who committed
suicide right and what if we found out
she didn't exist she she's alive yeah
you know I mean and she comes out she
goes wait I didn't die and I didn't come
out to you at all in fact I didn't like
your stand up at all matter of fact I'm
not even
transl what are you talking about like
Dave Chappelle is like and I jumped off
a building I killed myself like what but
I came back for you guys and then Dave
goes well this stuff does happen and
it's my emotional truth you Dave
Chappelle 's career would disappear like
that and let's even go even further
right how many times have we seen like
online um of like young ladies being
held accountable for lying about rape
accusations right and what if their
response was well it does happen to
women it's my emotional truth that's how
I felt in the moment that it could
happen to me you would [__] wreck
these women if they did that right so
why does he get a [__] pass he
doesn't he doesn't I and I think you
know he's he's catching the Flack that
he rightfully deserves and you know he
was uh I think in many people's eyes a
front runner to take over his host
that's gone that ain't going to happen
no more he's not going to become the
host of Daily Show after this you you'd
be surprised you'd be surprised if if it
happens bro like I'm on the fence I
don't think he's going to lose that much
opportunities which I think is just so
stupid it just kind of goes to show like
you could be the most untalented person
in the [__] room and you can make it
as far as you want dude yeah here's the
thing I think he what I meant by him not
understanding the unwritten rules of
maybe comedy or whatever I don't know I
think wrong the wrong it was the wrong
medium to be like that if he was to
write a screenplay yeah it's like he
understands the emotion of what he felt
right but on the screen and in the story
in order to help the audience feel like
he did he needs a story to do that right
I mean although in the moment he felt
that way it maybe wasn't that
extravagant in screenplay maybe you want
to play it up so it's like dude write a
movie write a TV show to you know tell
these stories they're fictional he was
he was trying to say this is Loosely
based on a true story but instead what
he said this is my
biopic this is what he did and like
people gravitated toward here's the
thing too like because he's in the
political realm and he's talking about
truths that are very serious topics and
once again I'm going reiterate this he
used real [__] people no I I know man
and look when he does something like
that when it when anytime bro you're
talking about something that's like
politically charged emotionally charged
racially charged right and he's talking
about it like as it's a matter of fact
it's truth then you're sewing doubt and
fear and ignorance into these people
right because people now are saying oh
they had a like a preconceived notion of
white people now they hear this story oh
yeah that's what that I knew it I knew
it yeah that's I knew white people are
like that or I knew black people are
like that or you know I knew brown
people are like that whatever the case
is I mean and that's the danger of what
he's doing he's he's framing it around
truth exactly and you know somebody I
saw a video where somebody said and I
very much agree with this person they
were like we live in a world now where
everything is so racially charged
sometimes it's very hard to get along
with somebody because you have a
preconceived notion about somebody
before you even meet them because of
stories like this right which do happen
but then when you start doing this stuff
where you start lying it gives those
people who are already sick of getting
[__] on all the time they go you're
crying wolf my dismissive right like
you're not doing anything good here like
what what is this it doesn't make he's
juicy Smo I was just gonna say
J Jessie SM I forgot his real name but
his name is juy now yeah look okay so
like you know [__] same [__] hey juicy
you get it pass now too right you didn't
do anything [__] wrong even though
you lied about uh what's it called the
hate crime where he it was like a
lynching yeah where for some reason they
bleach on him they put a rope around his
neck at a way please dude every black
person knew that story was fake
immediately automatically made no sense
like you like you're the guy on power
which no white people watch at all you
know what I'm saying and they recognized
you the most light-skinned dude of all
time and they decided to attack you and
the funniest thing about this story if
you guys don't remember was that the
people that he hired to do this were two
African dudes yeah yeah comedy so the I
think one of the other problems that was
mentioned I heard was that for the black
community too when they're watching
something like this cuz I I heard it
from a um this podcast from a black
voice where he he was saying you know
we're drawn in and we empathize with you
because of the the black experience in
America and for us to understand that
you went through this too we consider
you an ally but then you come around you
you just make this [__] up when we live
it it's like [__] you yeah sure [__] you
dude you know it's um it's it's an
insult I'm just going to do that now too
like every time somebody talks about
what they went through I'm just going to
mirror it you know and then at the end
it's like did you go through it no but
emotionally I told you it was true so
when basically when he says emotional
truth and I hate we're in an age now
that this is my biggest pet peeve
everybody has a specific type of
adjective a title or a something to
attach to it's like oh I was late today
oh actually I suffer from um late
drophobic ition where I always show up
late or you're a piece of [__] you know
like I I I get so sick of this and my my
biggest contention with this as well is
that people are so full of [__] now they
don't even know what the [__] they're
saying what is the biggest thing that
people say when you meet me Don't Judge
Me by how I look and who I am like don't
judge a book by its cover I don't like
titles and then automatically they they
go to titles like this is what I am like
no you do like titles you like being
defined by something and in fact you
can't even say who you are what you are
what you do without putting a title to
you this is who you are so don't give me
this [__] you know what I'm saying
and I I dislike that's why when I heard
that thing emotional truth stop making
up [__] yeah stop making up things for
you lying just say I lied it's my
emotional truth and I've went through
this with people personally like not too
long ago like where this person was
screaming at the top of her lungs about
all the lies she was doing and she goes
it's my truth it's my truth my God and
she screaming and everybody was like
listening to her as a group of friends
going it didn't happen though like no
but it's my truth it's my truth that's
how she felt when oh my God I I went
through that [__] too so like
um basically I I gifted somebody a a
guitar I told him to take care of it and
all that and then um I walked in on them
tearing it apart they they pulled it
apart and stuff and I was like yo what
are you doing right she's like what I'm
doing this I was like I I told you that
the aerros Smith guy set all this up and
it didn't matter she didn't even know
who AOL Smith was oh Jesus Christ so I
was just like oh my God and I was just
upset right and then that kind of made
our relationship weird as friends and
then later we had a smoke sesh you know
and we we hashed it out right and she
told her side and she said I came in
blazing like I put my hand at the guitar
I was like what are you doing stop you
you don't know what you're doing like I
didn't say any of that I was from my
perspective from what I I remember being
like shocked and really upset at myself
because I'd given this guitar this to
her listeners this podcast is brought to
you by nordvpn if you're online surfing
around snooping around doing whatever
the heck you're doing I don't care what
it is and it's none of my business it's
none of your aunt's business none of
your mom's business and as sure as heck
is none of the business of those people
out there who's just looking around to
see what you're doing try to steal your
information well that's when nordvpn
comes in and it just doesn't go for web
browser we're talking about surfing the
internet in general or just watching
videos online YouTube uh Netflix
whatever that it is you should get a VPN
and if you've been online without
getting n VPN you're doing it
unprotected and you need to be on your
cyber security chisel my friends because
those cyber threats be approaching all
over the place and that's where nordvpn
comes in this is an exclusive deal grab
the nordvpn deal go to nordvpn.com
geniusbrain and get extra subscription
time try it risk-free now with a 30-day
money back guarantee thanks to nor VPN
for sponsoring our
show this podcast is brought to you by
few my friends cold turkey may be great
on sandwiches but there's a better way
to break your bad habits we're not
talking about some weird mind voodoo
from your crazy neighbor or some some
other BS we're talking about our sponsor
fume and they took a look at the problem
in a different way not everyone or
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of drastic uncomfortable change
why not just remove the bad from your
habit instead of vapor fume uses
flavored air fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
does just that instead of electronics
fume is completely natural and instead
of harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors you get it instead of bad fume
is good it's a habit you're free to
enjoy and makes replacing your bad
habits easy your fume comes with an
adjustable airflow dial and a designed
and it's designed with movable parts and
magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do which is helpful for
de-stressing anxiety while breaking your
bad habit my friends my friends my
friends surprise The Taste the first
time you try it is a lot more flavorable
than you thought and it just feels so
refreshing The Taste The Taste the taste
I can't stop saying it because let me
tell you something stopping is something
we all put off because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fume has served over 150,000
customers and has thousands of success
stories and there's no reason that can't
be you join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trif nume.com and use code
genius to save 10% off when you get the
journey packed today that's try f.com
and use code genius to save an
additional 10% off your order
today the way that you can use emotional
truth in in entertainment art or
whatever right Eminem killing his wife
yeah did he no no no but it was a hit
song Stan you know did that guy really
no maybe the emotional truth behind that
is like he had a very rocky relationship
with his ex-wife the other one being his
fans are crazy as [__] yeah right but
did these stories really happen no he he
he painted a picture he told the story
kind of thing right this is what I mean
with like movies and TV shows who do
that too like bio P right some biopic
you'll watch and you're like that that
didn't happen right but like um did you
see the jobs movies the one with ashon
Kutcher and then the one with Michael
fast Bender right Michael fast Bender
one is far superior a because um Aaron
sorin wrote it and and he's also a
better actor yeah he's a much better
actor yes and the other one I I Learned
was the um Ashton Kutcher one like the
guy who wrote it was just some neppo
baby his dad financed the entire movie
and he said my son has to write it oh no
and so basically if you see that it's
like a book report of the Steve Jobs
biography which I also read so it's like
if you watch the it's called Uh jobs for
Ashen cutcher the Ashen Kutcher one it's
like facts of it's a biopic and then a
bit of
embellishment right and then there's
like it's like his entire life story
right
but then the what was the purpose what
is your emotional truth it was just to
sell the fact that Steve Jobs was a
genius yeah he changed the world great
guy yeah he's like this but then the
Michael fast Bender one it's not a you
know Cradle to the Grave biopic it's
broken into three acts like a stage play
it's like 30 minutes before his big
keynote presentations on these huge
launches right and in between that it's
about his relationships with the people
he worked with that defines his
character yeah did these arguments 30
minutes before keyot actually happened
no they were compilation of stories of
like true to their character how they
behaved and how they act right did it
happen there in that moment no but it
did happen in another timeline another
place but it was to drive the character
and story and the growth and where
they're going with it right how do you
do that with standup comedy
yeah you're just telling a lie yeah
people go there and you're seeing a live
person speak unless you know that
they're just I'm I'm here telling and
it's the problem with it is that he's
telling a lie in guys that it's the
truth yes you know what I mean yes if
it's a lie and it's a blatant lie and
everybody knows it's a lie nobody gets
hurt because now we're laughing at this
lie yeah he made it sound like it was
100% factual this is how it went down
and he did it with visual cues like this
is real life and with emotional beats
yeah and he slowed down his his his you
know his Cadence and my daughter was
hurt I mean I mean but like when you're
framing it pres yeah when you're framing
it and presenting it that way there's no
reason to doubt though you know what I
mean like you don't look at that
thinking oh this guy's lying and he's
full of [__] yeah you're thinking oh wow
that's that's pretty heavy [__] a
conversation too where his writers would
confront him like Hey this isn't he goes
no it's fine you know it's okay it's
like it's I the point is going to get
across the other way I was like no there
is no point if this isn't true there is
no point if this is not true you have
nothing and if your life is already
interesting enough as it is go ahead and
work it around that but once again it is
not about him making people laugh and
creating good material about comedy it's
about how do I might make myself look
like the victim and look good how do I
push this agenda you know yeah man I
mean and and look it's it's like when
somebody like that um who who is you
know somebody who's like more liberal
and like all of us we tend to be more
liberal with social issues right we see
that we call that out that's [__]
you know like you don't do that you
don't [__] lie about [__] like that
to push your political agenda and real
people and and that's something that
people need to practice a lot more of
these days I'm not going to mention
anything specific but when your side so
to speak is bullshitting and lying and
grifting you got to call him out on that
[__] right and Hassan is no exception
the fact that he's uh doing this under
the uh title of a comedian is even worse
because it's it's not funny that well I
mean again that could be subjective but
to me it's not that funny it's
objectively not funny yeah and two
you're [__] straight up lying you're
not you're you're making up stories to
make your again make yourself seem like
the victim the hero and and Martyr so
what happens to the other side of the
you know let's say the conservatives
right they see juicy Smo story and then
and then they see Hassan Minaj's story
and what do they say see white people
aren't out there doing this [__] they're
making it up and they'll they'll just
stop say we're all lying right like e
even the [__] that happened to me I've
told many stories of the racial attacks
that I've lived through through school
and my grocery store my gas station all
that like those experiences like really
happened they felt [__] terrible you
know yeah absolutely but when I tell it
I retell it so that people will laugh
cuz I don't want people ending up being
angry for me the the way I was left
feeling cuz it's not good that kind of
emotional manipulation like I could do
that I could tell these stories in a way
to make the audience start hating white
people if I was a piece of [__] like
that yeah you know or make make you
think some certain way don't go out
there you you know it's dangerous or
whatever right because on the other side
of that too you know what happens when I
go back home and I and I tell people
yeah I'm I'm here from La they go uh you
live in LA yeah because they literally
think it's a hellscape I mean yeah look
skidrow is bad the homelessness problem
is bad but you know what every major
city in America has a homelessness issue
it's not just here by the way every
major city America is busting over their
homeless into Skid Row yeah yeah yeah
yeah how are there 880,000 homeless
people in LA are they all from La no no
no for sure for sure not for sure not
all of this is doing is creating more
chaos and honestly like for me with like
like I said I'm not trying to victimize
myself I'm trying to make the the
situations I've been to through funny
but I have to admit yes I was a victim
in these things you know and what I
experience from other people let me say
is a lot of empathy and a lot of support
from my friends cuz what I realize from
people in La is because that racist [__]
doesn't always happen all the time every
day in La like I'm not experiencing that
at all people leave each other alone
right but they see these crazy stories
on the internet and people in La I've
said it before have that VI arious PTSD
yes that this bad [__] is happening so
we can't allow it to happen even if it's
not happening to them personally it's
not happening to them personally no
there was actually a recent segment on
Fox News where they were trying to paint
Seattle like that I saw that saw of
course I saw that clip they were trying
to show all these homeless people and
like they were painting it like there's
all these drug addicts and then they
interviewed locals like no it's fine
like nothing nothing happened then yeah
the the guy with the mic was like you
know I just just saw a guy shooting up
on my way here he's like she go did he
hurt you yeah did he hurt you yeah I was
like well I was in my car and she goes
oh you were in your car you okay and
they this on Fox News like this isn't
helping you guys like what the hell was
the point of that just like mind your
business yeah I mean look there are I'll
tell you this though when I went to uh
downtown Portland right like Portland is
beautiful like during the summer and
stuff like that downtown Portland though
has been affected pretty B I was
actually shocked I went there recently
for a wedding and so if you're from
Portland you can clarify this for me I
only heard this from you know a couple
of people I was talking to lived in
Portland at the time um and so I I was
there and then I saw a dude tweaking out
on the floor foaming at the [__]
mouth you know uh we were walking by
this guy screaming to himself you know
reminded me of of [__] skid Ro was it
Portland OR La so I thought it remind me
of skid Ro and then from in the morning
we were looking for places to eat and
there's like a couple of coffee shops
open here here and there and a few food
spots but a majority of the places were
closed and I asked why they're like oh
because you know Portland has a law that
basically people can camp wherever they
want do whatever and they uh
decriminalize drug use drug so the
people are literally shooting up doing
drugs doing whatever the [__] they want
out in the public they have these tents
everywhere but at 5:00 they're not
allowed to Camp there so they'll clean
up at 5 there's a
curfew so around 5:00 that's when they
have to get up and move and then
restaurants will open up but in the
daytime no restaurants open up because
everybody's just [__] shooting up
Drugs That's so wild and then they'll
give them a ticket right decriminalized
but they're like I don't [__] have
money well what are you going to do if
you give a homeless guy a ticket you
know what I mean make sure you sh the
court exactly we're going to find you
we're going to come get you I don't even
show up for my
kids the [__] are you talking about and
so they'll just take the paper and the
[__] roll a BL it's like hey Bill
it's 459 we got we got to hit that take
that last hit and get out of here
like man I personally hate Portland I
mean because I'm from Seattle obviously
there's like a city rivalry but
literally every time I've been there I
haven't had a good time but the last
time I was there um it was I was on a
road trip and it was during the George
Floyd protest so there was like a
massive scene going on downtown and so
me and my friends we were like we got to
get out of here so I got on an e scooter
and I'm leaving right and this white
lady with the black leather jacket these
big Gucci sunglasses and a designer bag
with a coffee in our hand is walking my
way and I'm going this way right and
then she takes a drink of her coffee and
I'm coming by and
she spits her coffee out in front of me
and I had to stop and I'm looking at her
and she goes the revolution is that way
and so cuz she's going to the protest
and I'm trying to leave the city so what
am I like a scab or something you think
I signed up for this I don't like that
that I'm getting out of here before you
guys you crazy rich white people do some
crazy [__] dog I'd be getting sick of
like people just thinking they could do
whatever they want and not getting
socked in the [__] face man like man
or woman you spit on somebody whatever
happens to you after you have to be
willing and ready for those consequences
because you just spit at somebody full
of coffee dude I was shocked like I'm
not saying I would sock her in the
[__] mouth but I'm saying that if she
does get socked in the mouth she's
easily going to just start playing
victim I was just trying to go in
support of all the atrocities and this
SC hit me so I got to punch Ed right now
cuz he just spit on me
tell but I mean like what was I supposed
to sh she does that tells me the
revolution is the other way so you know
what you're right I turned my [__] E
scooter around like let's go
let's go you know aab and you know
people have been really smart now where
you know in the beginning we I used to
get caught up in all this stuff too
where people will only show let's say
that was recorded right and they would
only show a part of something right like
they'll show let's say it was you a
somebody else and that lady got socked
in the face by this other girl right she
started wailing on her and they're like
look at this [__] this person hates
black people and they don't want to do
but they see the whole video now and the
whole video is her spitting as somebody
you know what I mean and we're getting
smart about this stuff because people
can go ahead and tell narrate their life
however the [__] that they want you know
what I'm saying and then we just believe
anything that we see and that happens a
lot now and I still get caught up in
that stuff where I'll see a video and
I'll go what the [__] hold on a second
let me see the whole video you know for
sure always tells a different almost I
would say like 80 to 90% of the time it
always tells a different [__] story
this is why context [__] matters like
in this case too when we go back to
Hassan like your context does matter you
did not tell the truth at all yeah I
mean it you know if you can just make up
anything to [__] prove a point that
you're trying to
make think of what the world would
become you know what I mean like you you
can't do especially when you're somebody
with a platform you got to be a little
bit more responsible with [__] like that
yeah there was another one where he
talked about how after 911 his mosque
was raided by the FBI or Homeland
defense undercover an undercover oh oh
yeah under
yeah and then he was talking to him
about what you're going to do he like
I'm going to get my pilot's license as
his joke and then um then the next thing
he knew his head was on the [__] hood
of a car and then everybody was in front
of the MOs looking at him like oh my God
hotan it's like you know I'm sure that
[__] has happened before to somebody
right if you're that great of a
Storyteller just say this happened to
this guy Dave Chappelle told a
compelling story about what happened to
EMT till yeah millions of people had no
idea who emit till was until he he gave
that story it wasn't a story about how
he got victimized in Mississippi while
he was visiting you know and then he
died and so his mom had to have a open
casket funeral for himself that'd be so
funny if he's talking about that as
himself but you're alive yeah exactly
but I came back to tell you guys or even
if he said like it was my baby cousin
yeah right like you didn't have to do
any of that type of stuff but once again
like you know maybe I'm beating this
drum a little too much but we go back to
the story and it's him on the hood being
racially discriminated for this atrocity
that happened he is the Martyr once
again when easily he could have told
that story about somebody else but if he
tells it about somebody else remember
he's not getting the glory you're a
narcissist that's the only thing happens
you can get the audience just as engaged
if you're telling a true story that
happened to somebody you know or
somebody else or was in the news and you
can explain it so it turned out this guy
that he's talking about once again is a
real person and he has no clue what the
[__] he didn't he was in apparently he
was in jail at the timeo yeah he was
like he was like I was in jail at how
that's not even possible the timeline's
not matching up and then this moralist
[__] bastard just goes like yeah I
lied like it's absolutely nothing like
you [__] piece of [__] you're
literally a trash bag you know that
makes you wonder how he even found out
about this guy in the first place to to
use his name as the undercover call him
a NC yeah like what well I no I think I
think he actually is like uh in in the
FBI or something right yeah yeah he he
but but he was in jail I don't know what
he was in jail for at that time but yeah
the timeline wasn't matching up there so
so I'm just wondering like how the [__]
did Hassan get his name you know that he
got he got docks too like I said he's
using real people and I don't understand
why what's wrong with you the homecoming
one I think I remember he actually put
up a picture of her from her Facebook
and he just blurred her face that's it I
think that was blurred post in editing
at the show it was like her name in her
face apparently W and she was there at
the show too yeah and she was there at
the show so [__] just reminds me of that
loud obnoxious dude in high school that
thought he was funny all the time yeah
you say something funny he'll say it
louder to get bigger exactly 100% And
like you know what like Indian people
know this too what is the biggest
negative Indian stereotype it's actually
not the whole cury thing is that they're
[__] habitual Liars like in the Asian
Community the biggest thing that Asian
people [__] on Indian people for is that
they're habitual [__] Liars because
they're great storytellers and it's like
dog you're not doing anything for your
people right now dude anything it's like
you like there's like this clip that
went viral which was I think it was like
Gordon Ramsey talking to this um guy who
makes an amazing Biryani right and he
goes how old are you he goes 40 years
old I'm not it's not the exact numbers
but go watch it's like 100 he's like
wait what how are you 14 he goes yeah
he's 140 years old and that number keeps
changing constantly as he's telling it
and it's like that's like the the
biggest stereotype about any people with
there it's like it's like clearly you
can tell right the emotional truth
behind that is that we rever this
elderly man who cares about how old he
is or or or his emotional truth is that
he feels that old you know that he's
been through so much life that he feels
that old yeah and then you'll you know
we'll you can go through any Like Comics
like storytelling or if they've been on
podcast you can go through my stuff like
I'll tell the same stories but little
small things change all the time right
because the parts that I'm embellishing
I don't remember you know what I mean
I don't remember right or if I'm trying
to hide somebody's identity the name
Will Change like the scenarios will
change a little bit because I'm actually
a decent [__] human being and if I'm
using real people I'm going to change
the [__] name and change the scenario
a little bit you [__] trash bag but
what's worth what's worse guys the
emotional truth the the the type of
person who who justifies by saying you
know that's my emotional truth or the
type of person who justifies by saying
there is no truth yeah yeah I don't
[__] I'm just use that in court all the
time like they're going to clock me in
for speeding at 100 miles hour that's
your truth my emotional truth said 60
exactly your honor in your eyes that's
murder to me I was just helping them get
to the afterlife F and these people just
like I'll go back to that story while I
told that girl was just screaming this
is my truth this is my truth and like
what she did outright physically harm
people like it affected everybody's
personal lives and the only thing she
kept screaming like a maniac was this is
my truth this is my truth and everybody
just went dead silent like this didn't
happen though so what what are we saying
here what why are we having this
conversation and that's what it left
that's where we left it at yeah that
this is my truth is like to let's agree
to disagree on the objective facts yeah
no we don't agree to disagree on
objective facts it's only facts yeah
it's only the truth there's not my truth
there's not an emotional it's the truth
a fact there's this is how I feel and
there's this is what happened those are
very two different things right so if
we're having let's say we're having a
discussion about let's say a car
accident right I crash into your car
right you were parking and I [__]
T-Bone you and then you say dude you
crashed into my car I was like that's
how you see it yeah exactly emotionally
speaking your car shouldn't have been
there right and then we're just then
there's like a deliberation with like
our insurance companies about the
emotional truth or are we talking about
what actually [__] happened what the
[__] are you saying and look I mean
serious things like do happen like for
example rape accusations right somebody
gets accused of rape and then they end
up in prison and you know later on you
find out oh no actually yeah I was just
pressured into into doing that and look
at that for all the other women that
need to be believed yeah when they have
actual accusations you know like I said
like I'm I'm curious to see what other
everybody else thinks like well and I'm
not going to take the comment of Like
Comics lie all the time we've already
delineated the difference you know what
I mean so that's that's a given given
the in comedy that Comics lie but again
it's what are you lying about and how
are you lying about it what's the end
goal why are you talking about it right
and for Hassan it was to glorify himself
yes high high level [__] narcissist
dude shout outs to Hassan minhaj you are
not funny you're a piece of [__] [__]
and I hate you and I'm pretty sure if we
had a conversation face to face which
most likely is not going to happen
that'd be great if you would though why
he come on this why it turn me around
I'm like dude this is a really good
guy I like him you know the funny [__]
is like some of the people who were
talking about this whole incident they
had had some interaction with his son
and some of them would preface it by
saying well he's a nice guy you know and
he he didn't do anything wrong to me but
we got to talk about this did you did
you see him on the LeBron James Barber
Shop talk show no I haven't seened
uninterrupted right so he's on there
with a bunch of other people but will be
with will be Goldberg and obviously they
start talking about politics and he
pissed her off so bad cuz I think he was
saying like your time is done old people
you guys had your chance you [__] it
up and then she goes hold on
[__] [__] you [__] you you don't
know what I did and what the older black
generation did for this country so you
can even stand here right now 100% And
then he was like he got sunned yeah well
like the audacity for you may not like
whoopy goldber be cuz she says a lot of
stupid [__] here and there you know what
I mean but I I'll say this right for a
lot of people who are in this
entertainment space who are you know
colored or other or whatever the [__]
that it is it took somebody else to take
those bullets right so it's like for
like black enter everything in
entertainment from our food like to
modeling like clothing everything just
came from like black black culture like
you got to give them credit for it and
for you to sit there as like an
Entertainer who's a color person in that
space who is also darker skinned to look
at what because go your time is done you
haven't done [__] the audacity dude [__]
out of here dude suck my dick is
essentially saying it's our turn it's
like hey [__] can you like relax
relax yeah right right I mean I I think
it's easy for people to forget that
there was a whole group of people many
groups of people before us who paved the
way for for for everything that we get
to enjoy today you know but when when
you know all you're caring about is just
this and that's how you get your facts
and your news [__] just reading tweet
headlines yeah you know not even
clicking not reading the article like
that happens so much or screenshotting a
tweet and with the headline and then res
sharing that no fact checking no fat
checking well guys that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast we
actually did a whole podcast on one
single [__] topic one topic I mean
but but it impacts a lot of things you
know yeah so uh in the comments below if
you're listening to this on the audio
side uh enjoy this but if you're on the
YouTube make sure you're write what did
you guys think about this whole
situation uh I'm just curious if you're
going to defend hust I'd like to hear
your thoughts about that if you just
like them then you like them that's fine
too uh genius brand every Sunday's at
12m um you could catch uh je everywhere
on every audio platform Ed at ed2 secret
society we are dropping our first line
of the Year very very very soon so stay
in tuned for that what I'm rocking right
now check out a couple of pieces is
there you could check Ed at at oh [__]
there's so many [__] ads dude Ed Park
Ed
Park and then uh Bible study at Momos is
Ed's uh podcast check that out as well
and we'll see you all next time peace
peace [__] Ed Ed eded I gotta pee
again oh
[__]